i'm quite comfortable sitting here
don't get me wrong my heart's beating so
loud i'm surprised you can't hear it
there's a lightness in my head and my
hand is a little sweaty
luckily i'm not only familiar with these
sensations
i enjoy them
over my career as an aerialist i've
learned to listen to those signs from my
body
whose most important job is to keep me
alive
this visceral sensation of fear can be
part of the fun
why do you think we go on roller
coasters watch horror movies
or in my case fly through the air
but it will only be fun if we have
choice in those moments
those who enjoy horror movies do so when
they know they can look away
when i swing through the air to take the
hands of a partner high up in a circus
tent
ultimately i have a choice of releasing
if i trust that person to catch me
listening to these signs is an
incredibly important life skill
and not just for adrenaline junkies like
me
if we don't know how to listen and
respond to our warning signs of fear
we risk being overwhelmed by a fight
flight or freeze stress response
when teaching circus i see my students
feel these sensations every day
and when they do there's a unique
opportunity to talk about them
to acknowledge and trust those feelings
including how to say no when something
doesn't feel right
this is a great foundation for
communication about our bodies
elsewhere that isn't scary or awkward
it's normal and expected because the
truth is
i'm not just teaching circus skills i'm
teaching consent
alongside teaching circus i have the
privilege of working with hundreds of
young people
each year in my role as a sexual harm
prevention educator
i hear their stories first hand and know
from statistics and experience that the
majority of survivors
know their abuser and teenagers
experience
high rates of intimate partner violence
that is from someone they're dating
young people want to know how to talk to
each other about intimacy
the more i help teenagers understand
sexual consent
the more i realize learning aerial can
help us navigate life on the ground
so let me explain what i mean by
teaching consent through circus
let's imagine it's your first time on a
trapeze
usual instruction might go something
like
okay you're going to hook your legs over
the bar climb your hands up the ropes
pull yourself to sit and don't let go
this approach
is driving something forward without
fully checking in with the person
and is focused on what i want from them
i'm telling them how to move their body
and when
regardless of their comfort or fear
this often results in terrified
beginners who never come back
meanwhile the way i now talk to my
students gives a lot more care to the
person
ensuring they're fully informed ready
and part of the conversation how do you
feel about it
really good yeah i feel like you could
probably do it do you want to have a go
okay that's it yes yeah but the inside
of your foot
that's it yes nice how does that feel
perfect good that's it i'm going to put
your hand my hand on your back
there you go i'm going to hold on to
your leg then i'm going to put my hand
here now do you feel safe to put your
hand on the bar
i got you how's that for you okay
yeah look i can stop you going forwards
and backwards see
woo i got you this type of language
like how are you feeling are you okay
with my hand here
help circus performers succeed i believe
it also reduces the risk of accidents
as a result of my students trusting and
being able to act on what they're
feeling
at any given moment this specificity
is required later in life if and when
someone wants sexual intimacy
but because it's not a normal part of
our interactions
it can feel so awkward and people might
think it's easier to say less
but saying less can lead to ambiguity
problems
and potentially abuse there is of course
no specific script for the language of
consent
the tone and words will be unique to you
it's just a slight reframing of our
lexicon to inject
choice any time we're interacting with
others bodies intimately or otherwise
for example using i when i'm talking
about what i'm feeling
and questions more than statements when
it involves the other person
when discussing intimacy check-ins like
does that feel good
do you like that in addition to letting
your partner know what you need
want and like helps us have experiences
we remember fondly
and have no regrets about we need to
broaden our understanding of consent
and start thinking of it as a verb not a
noun
to consent is an active ongoing
agreement
not a check box to be ticked when
talking to young people
we have an opportunity to show them what
it's like to communicate with care for
another person
checking in and respecting them as the
authority on what they're feeling
if we normalize consent everywhere by
the time someone is ready for a sexual
experience
they will know that they're allowed to
ask questions
stop at any time and most importantly
to enjoy themselves children are our
future
and they will learn to give care in the
ways we give care
sexual consent doesn't have to be a mood
killer
or the talk either like circus
it can be joyful fun and exciting
our intimate experiences should not only
be safe
but as thrilling as flying through the
air thank you